from the source the water flows through
channels into the terraced Gardens of
tip on built six hundred years ago it's
an idyllic place
300 people once lived here explains a
hydraulic engineer who's worked here for
decades the ruin is situated three and a
half thousand metres above sea level and
is considered a masterpiece of water
management people
t-phone was a huge ecological experiment
where the pre-hispanic people made use
of nature and especially water it was
used for rituals and ceremonies and also
for agriculture specific hydraulic
systems were developed for these
purposes for example the channels the
subterranean cisterns and the aqueducts
contain it is aqua cooking repite the
Incas succeeded in channeling the water
over a course of several hundred meters
down the hillside without it gaining
pace then sending it in various
directions to irrigate their gardens and
then on down into the valley
a few kilometers to the west is Cusco
the capital of the Inca Empire before
the Spanish conquest today over 2
million tourists visit each year the
city is thriving it's population booming
450,000 people live here but it hasn't
lost its unique atmosphere the legacy of
the Incas still survives even the course
of the river sarpy outside the city
limits is a testament to Inca history
like empty pond the water is channeled
into man-made basins to slow down the
flow that also helps remove debris from
the water but washed up trash is the
least of the problems much worse is the
raw sewage from thousands of toilets the
stench is overwhelming
this engineer works for the said a Cusco
water utility company which aims to
improve the situation
Len producer prop West oh really sorry
our goal is to decontaminate couscous
waterless D'Alessio
including here in the river sorry for
the the colic torres de la quebrada
sappy the water here is filthy and it's
our duty to rid the river of toxins
stop being as deceitful the problem is
the many new housing developments on the
outskirts of the city there are 50 in
the northwest alone all generate sewage
from toilets sinks baths washing
machines and dishwashers the river flows
in underground channels to the
neighborhood of San jerónimo at the
other end of the city from there it
flows into a sewage treatment plant
it's the pride of Cuzco it's been
undergoing renovation since 2014 with
the help of German consultants it's
being made more efficient
whereas now working in Peru's most
modern sewage treatment plant is very
gratifying it's also very challenging
look at the every day we investigate new
technologies and learn about how cities
in other countries are implementing them
things that are new to us in Peru what
do you ever are having with a blender
most of Peru's sewage ends up unfiltered
in rivers lakes and the ocean
it's dangerously unhygenic and an
environmental nightmare
Lucido mono produce a certain tasty
human waste generates approximately 75
kilos of carbon dioxide per year per
person if it isn't treated it could soon
be 400 Alanya kahuna plant this plant
allows us to reduce human generated
emissions to 20 kilos of carbon dioxide
per person per year a venti kilos the
gas is affecting the river Bollin
you can smell the improvement the
fermentation gas that accrues in sewage
treatment plants is now filtered out
more efficiently so the stench is far
less overwhelming much to the relief of
the plant's neighbors on Avenida kelana
for example this shop owner has been
living here for seven years the street
used to be notoriously
okay quando possible Carol when you came
here by bus the bus stop would be
announced as buenos uydess good air
that's what the neighborhood was called
no one would visit even the buses didn't
want to come here it was especially bad
at midday in the past when I would eat
over there with my mother-in-law we
thought at first that the stench came
from the bathroom and anyone who visited
us would notice the smell we'd always
tell them that it came from the plant
it's much better now
it smells a bit but it's nowhere near as
bad as them what it remote I was get up
in solemn delegations come from across
the country to visit the sewage
treatment plant on average two a month
the stench has largely disappeared
thanks to the optimized biogas facility
it prevents thousands of tons of
greenhouse gases from being released
into the atmosphere
pero es el momento nos encontramos we're
in the process of deciding on a
framework for the biogas team the plan
is for Cusco to convert two thousand
cubic meters of gas into electricity by
the end of the year the gas but I can
read a heretic the plant will soon be
completely self-sufficient the water
company will save over twenty thousand
euros in electricity costs per month the
only question that remains is how did
the Incas deal with sewage let me tell
you this is the bedroom no toilet and
the bathroom was probably adjacent you
can Ecole de baño the bathroom yes Hey
porque bang we assumed it was the
bathroom on the basis of the floor plan
and the ceramics we found no sushi
Arezzo
no he polis evidences researchers have
identified layers of organic material on
pots with layers of sand between them
suelo con algunas a slaughtered a
material on igano the Incas probably
used them as chamber pots then
not a beetle Annika the cat litter
principle perhaps the Incas value their
water supply too highly to befall it